Looks like we gotta do this again. Uh, because apparently Rachel McKinnon,
who is a, a trans cyclist as what has won yet another,
um, competition. What, as you understand.
It is their problem with you.
Competing I'm legally and medically female,
but the people who oppose.
Stop, stop, stop, stop. She's legally.
Medically female does not mean she's biologically female.
She's still biologically male.
Okay.
Oh see. She's very careful.
Ah, thank.
Okay. Medically just means that on your paperwork, it says, okay.
But the people who oppose my exist still want
to think of me as male being me as male.
A transgender man is a female who identifies
as a man. Yeah. Okay.
A transgender woman is a male who identifies as a woman.
You have to understand the difference between sex and gender.
Gender is a spectrum.
Okay? People, uh, shows traits of femininity,
androgynous that's in regards more to towards characteristic behaviors.
Sex is a matter of biology. And it's about your gonads.
It's about your chromosomes.
These are things that are generally imutable meaning you cannot change them.
That means that a male,
no matter how much they transition will never become a female.
You can't change your chromosomes. You can't change your internal organs.
A lot of your stuff aren't mutable your femaleness. Okay?
The fact that you're a female isn't based off of any paper or what a legal
person says, it's based off your biology, right? You can say you're a female.
All you want ladies, if you went on a day with a dude and he said he was six,
three, and you show up and he, I have to, and you be like,
you're not sixth street, like you said. And he's like, well, my paperwork,
my paperwork says six, three. It's a matter of biology.
Doesn't matter what the paperwork says. The reality's still the.
Reality.
And so there's this stereotype that men are always stronger than women.
And so if you think of trans women as men,
then you think there's an unfair advantage.
Again, very careful with language.
There's this idea that all men are stronger than women.
Nobody has sent that. No, no. Again, if I get in the ring with Ron Rousey,
she's gonna have her way with my butt. She will,
she's gonna tear into my butt butt. She is
gonna do what she's gonna tear into my butt butt. Oh, if.
You do that.
Because she can't. Cause she's stronger than me. <laugh>.
Cause she can't. But she gonna a.
<Laugh> Rhonda. Rousy about to get rowdy up in my butt butt. <laugh>.
Why are you so happy about.
That? So a rowdy rowdy I'm Rononda Rhonda <laugh>.
Uh, I'm pretty, it's a gonna hear that it gonna be a, a rosy, a Roussy <laugh>
oh wow. I hate.
Myself for that. So this idea that trains, athletes,
fear feel like it's fair for them to compete.
That there's no biological difference. And so I said cool,
but I also have a question. Why is it always transgender,
transgender females who are always winning and breaking these records?
Why isn't it men?
So here we have this article from pick news that says 10 transgender athletes.
Explain why it's fair to compete. So first up we have break from MCK.
Kidon a two time world champion trans cyclist. Uh,
she's been competing against women. Let's go to the next person.
Transgender triathlete, Chris Mosier. He is a transgender man.
Meaning he was born a female transitioned to man. He is one absolutely nothing.
So that's one for women, zero for men,
transgender fighter MMA fighter, Fallon Fox,
who is, has a record of six and one, including, uh,
most wins by TKO knockouts in the first round. On the other side,
we have a transgender man, meaning born a female,
transitioned to man pat Manuel who made history in 2008,
when he became the first transgender man to professional league box.
What's his record one. And oh, it's only had one fight. Who did he fight?
A fighter who was oh seven, never won a fight.
Laurel Hubbard who has won a few gold medals and beaten competitions as well as
competed in the Commonwealth games. She's broken records. Of course.
And then we have transgender swimmer.
Bylar he a transgender male, meaning born a female trans transition to man,
um,
was a winner up until 2012 transitioned and then never won anything ever again.
Now we have transgender wrestler, Mack begs,
who was born a, a female transitioned to man.
And he has won the high school state wrestling championship in 2017, 2018.
So this is the first transgender man who's won something at a high level.
Only problem is he's competing against women while on testosterone.
So we have a biological female on testosterone,
competing against women and annihilated the competition.
Even when they make their own articles,
have their best examples of biological female competing against
biological males. They never win anything.
They never compete at the highest level. They never show out in a real way.
But notice that all the biological males who transition and compete against
females, they are breaking record. So if this is so fair, how come there?
Aren't more transgender men winning.
Because it's not.
That's the answer because it's not the answer is because it's not. Sport is.
A, is a human right? Just explain what that means for.
For you. We care about the Olympics. We care about board.
It is central to society. So if you wanna say, well,
I believe you're a woman for all of society,
except this massive central part that is sport. Then that's not fair.
So fairness is the inclusion of trans women. Is it.
Fair when someone who has a crazy physiological and biological
advantage gets into a UFC ring and cracks the skull of a BI biological
female, not because the male is more talented,
but because the male is stronger,
faster and better built for fighting sports, ask any athlete.
If they want to compete against males.
And they all tell you, no, it's not because they don't work hard enough.
Cause I would never insult female athletes that way.
It's because they understand that there is a biological difference between them
and their male counterparts. It's too different.
So when you sit there and you say it's unfair to me to not let me, I'm like, no,
it is unfair to let you been in that sport.
Do you think you'd have been a world champion cyclist? If,
if you hadn't transitioned.
I don't think I am a world champion because I'm a trans woman.
I put in the work.
Who are you talking to? Who are you talking to?
This woman asked you a simple question and you going off left and right.
Who are you talking to? <laugh>
what's wrong, bro. You good? You like that? Yeah. It looked like me. Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry you, I was like, oh. That's me. Hey, you inspired me.
Don't it feel good though? Do it again. Who are you talking to?
<laugh> telling me to feel it again.
Who are you talking to put your hands in this?
<laugh> it's more in the shoulders. Who are you talking to?
This girl's bugging you. Yeah, but she's bugging,
but she's not answering the questions.
You can admit the fact that you work hard and also admit the fact that you have
a huge advantage because you are male. Yeah.
You both of those things can be true and you can still, yeah, you can.
You could still work hard.
And again, we have to remember, I lose most of my races.
I've lost against the specific CIS women complaining about me being unfair.
Yes.
You a regular male who trains hard,
lost against the top level athlete females.
It's because you are not that good because if you were you'd compete against
males and you would get destroyed.
The men's hundred meter record is 9.58 seconds. The women's is,
is 10.49 seconds.
There is an undisputable advantage for, for men in sport. Isn't there.
We talk about men being faster than women.
We have to be very careful what we're talking about.
So the example you gave was at the.
Most feed and strength sports, they have a 10, 10%,
12% advantage in most scientific opinions.
At the elite level. Right.
Which is what you compete at. You Guber.
<laugh> who are you talking to?
Did you not just win a car competition and a gold medal?
Who are you talking to? Who are you talking to at the highest level?
Yes. Where you competing? <laugh> you mad, man. What's wrong, bro.
She's out here trying to, you know, pretend she's righteous when you are.
Being disingenuous.
Yeah. So when we look at the very best athletes in men and women,
you see this roughly 10 to 12% gap.
But if we're talking about like the average man,
no that's but when we're talking about the.
IOC, we're talking about the elite level aren't we.
Of course, if you look with a single sex event,
the different between first and eighth is very large.
And the difference between first and first between sexes is often smaller
than the difference between first and eighth within a sex. What are you.
Talking about? What, what are you saying? What are you saying?
How does that even, that's not even a point. I know the top,
the top man and the top woman. There's a gap. There's a huge gap.
You the eighth man. And the first there's a reason why CEL,
Serena Williams lost to the 200 ranked man.
It's not because Serena William doesn't work hard decision.
Superly talented or she's in the best at her sport.
It's because Ben just have a physical advantage. It's a different sport period.
Men's.
Tennis and women's sense are completely almost two separate sports.
So I'm like if I were to play Andy Murray,
I would lose 6 0 6 oh and five to six minutes.
Maybe 10 minutes because no, it's true. It's, it's a completely,
it's a completely different sport. The men are a lot fast and me and um,
they, they get, they serve harder. They hit hard. It's just a different game.
And I love to play women's tennis. And I,
I only wanna play girls cause I don't wanna be embarrassed.
I would not do the tour.
So by that logic, would you not have male or female categories whatsoever? Ooh.
Ooh, tested. You.
Was right. I think that's a great question. I think that's a different question.
I think that <laugh> who are you talking to?
That's a different question. Answer.
It. So I think it's not fair to trans people to say, well,
in order to fix whether to include you in sport,
let's just radically shift how we do sport.
Isn't that what you try to do by competing in it.
That that's what you're doing right now, allowing you to compete is,
is radically changing the sport.
But you don't wanna do that because it's not fair to you now. Ooh. Okay.
Boo, boo hunter chicken, cherry child hunt bun bunch with a cherry on top. Nooo,
no hunter bun. That's what you got me up.
It's really some selfish about you.
Don't give a about the sport. Don't give a about women.
You don't about man. You just give about you and you winning.
That's what you give about.
Or is studied by the, the Swedish university, the, the Carol Institute,
which I know you've read, read closely.
It does say that there's very limited change in thigh strength,
12 months after transitioning and taking testosterone, suppressants,
thigh strength, as you know, more than anyone else, obviously a huge thing,
particularly in, in sport, but particularly in track cycling.
Do you accept that there, there may will be an advantage?
Is it possible? Yes. Um, however,
the range of body sizes and strength levels within a sport,
you can be successful with massively different body compositions,
even within my sport. So again, a, a British example would be Victoria,
Pendleton, teeny tiny skinny legs, best in the world.
The exception proves the rule.
If I look at NBA players and I look at the average high of some of the best NBA
players, they're pretty much all over six, seven, every single one of them,
the top 10,
all of them over six seven now have there been six feet tall NBA players
who've excelled and done extremely well of, but they are a small minority.
I would not look at them and say, Hey guys, that's a norm.
Height is not important. We can. All of course, it's important.
There's a reason why NBA Scouts. When they look for players,
they look for players above a certain size,
a certain weight because these things have a huge,
huge impact on how skilled and how good you can be at the NBA for her to sit
there and to make this argument.
Is it more important that that trans women
feel that they're included than to maintain a
category within sport?
I think you're,
you're asking me is like trans women inclusion more important than fairness in
sport. But again, my point is that trans inclusion is fairness. Um,
it is unfair to exclude legal and medical women,
trans women from women's sport or part of society.
So this is much bigger than sport in that it's,
it's the proxy for all of trans inclusion in society. Um,
talk of,
of bathrooms has shifted into sport by people who don't care about sport.
So I think it's clear that this issue is bigger.
So look, when they talk about fairness, they talk about all this stuff.
I'm like, yo, you guys can say whatever you want,
what you guys are doing is you're destroying women's sports.
That's essentially what you're doing.
You're allowing else to infiltrate a place predominantly occupied by
females, right? And the,
the whole point of having female sports is to allow them a chance to shine on
the big stage. And now you're going to Rob them of that. By allowing these,
these people who know they have an unfair advantage to compete against them.
This is trash it's garbage. And when I, I said this in the other video,
I was called transphobic.
Apparently it's somehow bigoted or it's hateful to say, Hey,
I want you to play on an evil playing field. Well, how about you're a bigot?
Sure, sure. You know,
if I don't want to see a male compete against a female in a boxing competition,
maybe I'm bigoted,
but you go look at the person who skulls broken in and you tell her that's fair.
That was fair in the name of wokeness. Amen.
Amen. <laugh> amen. I kill my.
Own though, bro. I, I, you know what?
I'm when the athletes who actually compete in these areas don't want the changes
that you're imposing.
Maybe you recognize that you as a normal person may have the wrong opinion on
this topic. And look,
if you guys do know any examples of transgender men who are winning at the
highest level, killing it, police by all means, inbox me, prove me wrong.
That's all I got for today. Leave your commons boat.
Was to transition at a master's level. If he was to take,
take testosterone suppressants for it for 12 months and then compete at a
master's level against Victoria Pendleton, he would beat Victoria Pendleton.
She, she would beat Victoria Penton.
Would Chris. We don't actually know that again.
We are making this massive assumption. Um.
But I think that's a fair assumption to make don't no.
We, we haven't seen this in the rest of sport.
So again, trans women have been allowed to openly compete since 2004,
since the 2004 Olympics, since the 2016 Olympics,
you didn't require genital surgery. And we didn't see a single trans person.
So it was already the case that an unscrupulous country could have taken
someone like Chris and met the testosterone policy,
gave 'em a passport for female and said off you go to Rio. Didn't.
Happen.
The reason why they didn't do that is because they have values and morals and
they recognize it's unfair.
So even the most unscrupulous country looks at your behavior and says,
I would never emulate that. This isn't a point for you.
It just proves how trash you are.